if I told you about her the princess  without voice what would I say  [Music]  she deaf he he can hear you you clean  that lab to get out this may very well  be the most sensitive assets ever to be  housed in this building you may think  that thing looks human stands on two  legs right but we're created in the Lord  Jim you don't think that's what the Lord  looks like there this creature is  intelligent capable of language of  understanding emotions  [Music]  you  when he looks at me he doesn't know how  I am incomplete he sees me as I anybody  but the natives in the Amazon worship  this oh my god get him out what are you  talking about you need to take it apart  learn out I don't want an intricate  beautiful thing destroyed we could do  nothing I'm sorry don't think that the  last I do this  if I told you about her what would I say  I wonder  [Music]  you  [Music]  you